we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to David P I recently did a
segment on the Pacman Finance Channel
recommending what I believe to be 10 or
so personal finance books that if
everyone read you would be ahead of 98
of the population in terms of personal
finance knowledge I did that segment
last week
someone wrote in I'm sorry they called
in and they said David what about Rich
Dad Poor Dad take a listen to this
David it's Alan from Jersey I'm watching
your video on the Pacman Finance Channel
about yes uh Finance books you've
suggested and your list did not include
Rich Dad Poor Dad by Robert Kiyosaki I
can't believe you left this one out I
know
is one of the best Finance books that
teaches you the difference between
thinking like a rich person versus
thinking like a poor person
for example poor person works hard pays
their taxes and gets screwed over when
their company lays them off but a rich
person like Kiyosaki writes a scam book
Ms Rich Dad for an ad scam book then he
gets in bed with Amway which is a scam
multi-level marketing thing yes and
forces and wanting people to buy his
book and that's part of his whole scheme
uh that made him the self-help Guru so
yes the Robert kiyosaki's main strategy
for getting rich is to write books and
sell them to people telling them it's
going to tell them how to get rich so if
you can emulate that that is that is a
way now listen I read Robert kiyosaki's
Rich Dad Poor Dad like the first couple
of books when I was probably 16 or 17
years old and I don't find them
substantive and I don't find them
serious now whether he is a quote
scammer or not I will leave that to the
critics to decide but if you say to me
David sir I need recommendations for
personal finance books that are really
personal finance it's not Kiyosaki
telling me to get get just get start
getting real estate that will generate
passive income uh and then buy more of
my books and maybe do some Amway stuff
no if you want my actual list of good
Finance book recommendations go to
davidpackman.com recommendations and
then we also have the finance content at
youtube.com pacmanfinance I do not
recommend Robert kiyosaki's books or his
courses or his whatever it is that he is
selling the books I recommend are cheap
they are complete and that they aren't
going to try to sell you more stuff
um and again if you read these 10 or so
books that I recommend to you your
personal finance knowledge will be
greater than that of 98 of the adult
population I I've got nothing to sell
you they're not my books they're other
people's books uh youtube.com Pac-Man
finance and davidpackman.com
recommendations on today's bonus show
the FDA wants to simplify the use in the
updating of covet vaccines what do they
want to do and who is already flipping
out about it I think you can probably
guess the first artificial
intelligence-powered robot lawyer is
going to represent a defendant in court
next month this is super interesting and
we're going to discuss it at length on
the bonus show and lastly the woke mob
oh wait no it's the right wing mob the
right wing mob has indefinitely paused
their Eminem spokes candies over
right-wing pressure
I thought we were the people who
canceled but they are doing a lot a lot
of canceling sign up at joinpakman.com
you'll get instant access to the bonus
show I will see you then